in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
for chronically ill people relaxation
and getting away from it all is
especially important with me in the
studio is dr. Tomas jellineck he's an
expert on travel medicine welcome why is
traveling with illnesses such a problem
it may be a problem because travelling
means change change in life situations
and that may mean that you need to
change your medication that your body
reacts differently to climate or to
whatever you do and many chronically ill
patients are not prepared to react
adequately so dares to risk and that
needs to be prepared okay let's let's
take a look at an example like high
blood pressure if you suffer from
hypertension what you have to watch out
for hypertension usually means you take
tablets to get the high blood pressure
down and that's how you live when you
travel blood pressure changes actually
it goes down usually because the climate
changes and that may mean that you over
medicate that you actually take too much
of your drugs because your body now
reacts differently and you don't need
that amount and that you need to know
and you need to prepare it before you
get problems and you mean the climate
changes it puts the blood pressure down
because you go into a warmer climate
yeah or is it even if you say travel to
the North Pole now it's not a North Pole
usually that's causing problems and
that's not a such frequent destination
is usually realm climbs people go to and
they're just because you need to add to
a to adapt to the warm climate the blood
vessels go go open in the skin and that
means that your blood pressure goes down
okay what about some real serious
disease like cancer Kevin people
suffering from cancer travel actually
usually they are frequently day a day
want to travel because they want to have
something nice and alive again as well
and they can yes unlike 10 years ago we
have now lots of hotels and cruise ships
and things like that that are prepared
to cater for patients that need
medication it's just you need to prepare
the journey you need to talk to you to
plan it before you start booking it and
then you can do a lot of things a lot of
travel even with cancer even with other
diseases so see the doctor first before
booking and if a patient comes to you
and say I want to travel you
some kind of travel pack with
medications in it yeah travel pharmacy
is of course a good idea to carry and
things like diarrhea like pain like
wounds of the skin should be treated and
can be treated by the travel themselves
so a simple travel pharmacy is a good
idea and it's good to talk with the
doctor about that too many of my
patients coming to into my office and
say they want some antibiotics just for
precaution they don't want to take it
just want to take it with them and so
what do you think about that again a few
years ago we said it's not a good idea
to take an antibiotic because it's a
drug you may harm yourself with as well
but things change because for for a
start we learned that our travelers
actually don't take them lightly they
only take them if they are really in a
crisis like bloody diarrhea and so on
and second and more important we have a
huge problem internationally with fakes
with falsified drugs particular in Asia
and Africa so it may not be safe to go
to a pharmacy even a big city and get
your antibiotic that you need it's
actually in many instances safer to
carry it with you and to use it if you
need it so Indians you always have to
think that you could take your current
medications with you you're on because
if your hypertension patients say you
have to take your own medication there
and don't rely on the pharmacies on the
destination that they have it there too
absolutely okay great dr. le neg what do
you predict ations used to prevent
motion sickness we have a drug which is
called scenarios in which we prefer to
give particular for for seasickness
because it doesn't make tired so you
don't need to sleep and it's working
fairly well as well but it's not all
medication you can do some something to
prevent it like tricks like like
choosing the right seat on a plane so
what about that yeah it's in a ship you
would go to the Middle where the motion
of the ship is lowest and there the
likelihood is is highest that you have
less symptoms you can watch the horizon
so your eyes notice that you're moving
and so on this is working sometimes
sometimes it doesn't but what can try
this as well let's get into air travel
one of the major risk of air travel is
getting a thrombosis
perhaps because of sitting in the
economy class that's why it's called
economy class syndrome so how do
patients recognize that they gotta trim
versus if you got it thromboses it's
painful it does further than the leg
because there's a blood clot and the den
den the leg swells up and is really
painful it's dangerous to because if you
now stand up and move to blood clot
might be released again and might float
into the lung and then it's actually
life-threatening so does this mean if
you land in the plane did you see that
you're like a swollen you should stay
seated yeah if you're if you really have
a painful swollen leg you should stay
seated you should inform the flight
attendant and ask for medical help
because if you now now start moving it
really might cause a lung embolism and
that's life-threatening it 8's happened
before even in lung in young people okay
so how can we prevent getting a
thrombosis because it's much better to
prevent it and one is to drink a lot of
water in the plane if you manage to get
it from the flight attendants was
difficult get some time Daisy second
thing is very simple book seats at the
aisle not at the window eighty percent
of them boses do happen at the window
because Eddie are you simply have to
move more because people have to go to
toilet you have to get up and so on and
then there's something like travel socks
which is a socks you that are quite
tight and if you if you wear them your
blood flow is faster from the legs so
that's a fairly potent prevention of
some bows as s 1 what about taking
aspirin medication against clotting s
dream has been popular for a while but
it's not working in the veins it's just
working and the arterial system so it's
okay if you had a heart disease but not
against from bos it actually it might
even harm so it's if you do have to take
drugs or something like heparin or other
drugs that work but that's only for
high-risk travelers and Stacia to talk
to talk to their doctor before they do
it of course I'm in on smokin I don't
smoke I don't like it and but people who
smoke and they are if they are on an
intercontinental flight they have to not
smoke for say 10 or 20 hours to how do
they manage that that's not easy
actually because if you're doing smoke
regularly like 26
per day you actually need to nicotine
the whole time and if you don't get it
because you can't smoked and you might
get agitated aggressive and many
instances of a our age and planes
actually are caused by smokers they can
smoke so one should think about that
problem and one should prepare and
that's again fairly easy actually you
just need to need to take nicotine
tablets or chewing gums and use them
during the flight and then nothing
happens ok great good to know Priscilla
Nick thanks so much for being with us
new kitchen thank
you